بمناسبه او بدونها الغرب وحلف شمال
الاطلسي يؤكدان مرارا وتكرارا انهما لا
يودان التورط في الحرب باوكرانيا غير ان
المؤشرات قد تقود لعكس ذلك تماما نقطه
التحول في المعادله طائره اف 16 وشبه
جزيره القرم
مقاتلات ستكون في يديك قريبا هي مساعده
عسكريه غربيه للجيش الاوكراني من اجل
الدفاع عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه كل الاراضي
وفق واشنطن البيت الابيض اعلن انه لا
يمانع استهداف شبه الجزيره التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا العام 2014 منطقه تعتبرها
موسكو جزءا من اراضيها هنا تكمن كلمه السر
او نقطه التحول في المواجهه بين الغرب
وروسيا القرم قد تصبح نقطه رماديه خطيره
ستجعل الولايات المتحده والناتو مشاركين
مباشره في الحرب
ستدعم مبادره مشتركه لحلفائها لتدريب
طيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات اف 16 خلال
مده التدريب الذي سيستمر لاشهر سيقرر
الغرب موعد تسليم الطائرات وعددها وكذلك
الدول التي ستوفرها روسيا شددت على ان
ارسال هذه المقاتلات الى اوكرانيا سيثير
تساؤلات عن ضلوع حلف شمال الاطلس في
الصراع واي هجوم اوكراني على شبه جزيره
القرم سيعد هجوما على روسيا تقول موسكو
مقاتله اف 16 والهجوم على شبه جزيره القرم
قد يجران الولايات المتحده وحلف الناتو
الى معترك المواجهه المباشره واشنطن لا
ترغب في التورط وقد تتبرا من اي هجوم
محتمل لكن فوق اجواء القرم رياح مضطربه
وخطيره بلال الوجداني العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات